Game one um let's go d4 and well I got
the old benoni defense and okay I've
seen this quite a bit so it's getting
ready for a quick Bishop e7 to g5 stuff
I might already want to take that into
account because why black would want to
go with this is because this is his bad
bishop to begin with it's my good guy
and well I doubt Bishop here if i play
my knight here then it could there could
be a pin could I really prevent that if
I want to prevent this idea maybe h3
Knight f3 I'm just gonna run forward
with more development
okay well black isn't running with that
are they okay Wow let's play bishop mmm
bishop where you throw it check in let's
see if I could get rid of my
LightSquared bishop although sometimes
this guy could just be a problem for as
long as it remains on the board and I'm
forgetting that this is a three minute
one let's do this so if there's gonna be
an exchange I'll really look into
caption with the pond so I could get
some play here and with that move I'm
actually gonna come all the way back cuz
I'm pretty sure this is now
uncomfortable for the LightSquared
bishop I'm inserting this first before
Knight f3 so that the bishop is so that
the the Queen side is really a bit
difficult to get organized and I think
as a follow up going immediately for
this is good because it's gonna stop a
knight pivot on this square if my
opponent is not careful I could be
playing a 5 and a quick piece at Knight
b6 this is likely the move to be played
the fr can open up quickly but I do have
support for it and well if if I could
get an a5 Knight b6 and force the r up
to this square I think I'm already
successful because this rook will be
really out of position I'm gonna run
with it right now
so that's that's a tough spot now and I
think castling right away if well okay
hmm
I think I'm the better developed how
about I go with this now how about I got
this one of the two or how about I
retreat I don't maybe I don't allow that
capture yeah let me I'm not gonna allow
the capture I'm gonna put pressure on d6
and that was missed I'm on the Queen and
now I'm just gonna come back to where
though Oh actually I have to play here
I think because there's this Queen move
with the threat of Bishop takes pawn I'm
in a pin Queen here
okay would be hitting both the night and
pond I might want to consider this but
now I like keeping pressure on this pond
and I would really like to get oh boy
okay let's try this get rid of this good
attacker if this pawn push is played I
think I snipped the knight first and
then maybe capture something not sure
it's a little bit dangerous okay I don't
think it's it's not I don't think it's
dangerous now though just gonna do this
time and I just want to make a forcing
move get this square available for my
knight and you might want to consider
Bishop takes yeah let me go it no let me
do this first I'd like to just get the
Queen's off the board if I could be
assured of that I think things are quite
all right
okay make sure the Queen's are off and
try and just go quick now Knight takes I
could take this got to support that
about even with time and I have a knight
check here night is night move here's
available I want to do this just so this
Bishop doesn't come here watching out
for my king I was fearful the knight
check and Bishop their stuff when I get
my Bishop around to e and just want to
get that get rid of that Bishop even
though I'm dropping upon and how are
they going to recapture I want to come
over here where it's safe
and I probably have to watch over this
pawn or not I could just exchange rooks
I gave you check with the wrong night
let's come over here and try and get a
break in with this pawn push or
something oh I missed a fork again at b6
square don't really have anything this
is not the best technique at all for
sure these are just time burners cuz I I
just wanna make sure make sure that just
get the time ah man
good game those are tough to adjust to
I'm so used to the 5-minute ones and
then this one all of a sudden good game
but kak let me you can post that I mean
hit the back button flip and see if
there's something we could take away
from this I I don't know about what do
you do what's the correct move in
response to this Bishop check you block
with the knight or the bishop because I
could see it being uh pretty
uncomfortable or what about this this is
a pain isn't it I'm not mistaken is it
doesn't this turn out to be a pretty big
pain for black now to coordinate their
Queen side because this square is
sometimes sometimes the queen Knight
access is that a six square and then
reroutes in some way maybe eyes be for
for a moment or comes back to c7 to
support b5 I wonder I also wonder if
maybe it's okay to take even though I
would get a file I wonder if you could
just take and then maybe try for a six
although you're not threatening to take
just yet when you do that because
pin but maybe just take and then get
your night out and then play for a six
because otherwise he just turns out to
be a problem piece and gets in the way
of the queenside development so I'm
wondering if that's another thing you
could be looking into even though it
allows me a half-open file at least you
have to deal with that Bishop being not
so useful in the game so anyhow
something else to look into if this was
the first time experience that's
experiencing this on the blackened you
know that maybe maybe try something else
I I think I have experienced it myself
that's why I'm kind of maybe able to add
some insight into this because I I've
had to deal with this Bishop check him
live I blocked and then when I chased it
when I attacked it came back and then I
couldn't trade it off for anything it
was just kind of stuck so I don't I
don't know about this then cuz I'm
landing on b6 maybe before f5 is played
maybe you could try b6 or something and
meet a5 with b5 mind I could still get
here but at least you have a pawn on b5
and maybe you could be pushing my knight
away and your Brooke is able to swing
over laterally so I guess should this
still be a position maybe b6 is a little
bit more of an improvement instead of
going with the immediate f5 can't say
for sure just rough thoughts as usual